[Music]
slowing the kovat 19 pandemic is
Europe's number one priority while
Europeans are doing their part by
staying at home labs and researchers are
working day and night to develop a
vaccine better diagnosis and effective
treatment experts from the European
Centre for disease prevention and
control have been working tirelessly to
strengthen Europe's response to threats
posed by the disease every day they
produce scientific updates and
guidelines on kovat 19 getting enough
money for research is vital but the
Android can design mrs. Alma bite
combines a mesh Clady key with mere
invested to an unfortunate victim the
European Commission has put forward
multiple packages to support the
scientific community and pharmaceutical
industry emergency research funding of
47 point five million euros has been
allocated to 17 horizon 2020 projects
that will help advance knowledge to
respond to kovat 19
[Music]
to develop a corona virus vaccine cure
vac in Germany has been offered up to 80
million euros of European financial
support the EU is also helping to fund
solution orientated projects such as
epicotyl which makes isolation units for
patients and MTAC developing
technologies to filter viral particles
by helping project such as the European
virus archive and prepare Europe the EU
is supporting future diagnosis and a
better understanding of the outbreaks
dynamics as well as wider research into
epidemics a new call for proposals by
the innovative medicines initiatives a
partnership between the pharmaceutical
industry and the EU aims to develop
treatments and diagnoses and increase
preparedness for future outbreaks the EU
will contribute up to forty five million
euros through the horizon 2020 research
programme
[Music]